My inner revolution book.
Yeah.
I still think that definitely,
but we're just subverted that we're,
we're under the control of warmongers.
That's a moment of war criminals.
They are controlling us and taking all
the money and taking all their energy
and had,
they've controlled the media propaganda
vehicle and so on.
They've turned it into basically and uh,
so,
but,
but they are kind of desperate though
because they had been had but they're
not getting anywhere and the people are
getting more and more sick of it and
the,
and the people are,
have been for fooled into it and
frightened into it in various ways.
But I think that's kind of,
it's like it's the darkness before the
Dawn.
They,
I think the people will really refuse at
some point at this rate,
you know,
because um,
the Cold War and they were kind of happy
in the Cold War,
these criminal people because they had a
big enemy that they could promote that
they were afraid of.
They were very unhappy at the end of
World War II because we won.
So therefore they was no need to always
in American history before that.
As Gore Vidal brilliantly says,
we always demobilized,
but in 47 truman and others decided that
they would create this enemy and the
Russians are former great allies who
helped us beat the Germans.
Actually in the Italian was really good
Russian,
we're a major factor and they were our
major allies and suddenly it turned them
into the devil and the a threatened them
with nuke our nuclear weapons,
which then caused them to like build up
nuclear.
Then we could have an arms race for
them.
Then make them an enemy.
Then have all these proxy wars and the
happy days for the military have 40
years of cold war.
Then finally it stopped and they didn't
know what to do.
They're doing Bush one no more cold war,
no more things.
They,
even Bush one had the temerity,
the old warrior,
a CIA guy that he is to say we might
have a peace dividend and he's talking
there to all the poor people in America,
all the people with no decent roads and
schools and train systems and all the
horrible way deteriorate it
infrastructure that the u s now is a
victim of like a fourth world country.
And,
but no,
there's no peace dividend because the
old secretary of defense,
you know,
Darth Cheney writes up a big program for
world conquest.
And so everybody's our enemy.
Sadly then.
So it's even better.
We only had the Russians before and now
suddenly everybody is our enemy.
And then it's got to find some people,
okay,
let attack Iraq little attacks here and
there and we'll conquer from Iraq to
central Russia,
you know,
and get all the oil.
You know,
I mean,
it's ridiculous thing he wrote in 1991
which they'd been doing now in 2000 with
the poor,
the poorest son who was just a party
animal who just,
you know,
wants to sniff coke and have fun.
And they just put him up there and he's
like going like this and they don't
here's know what he's doing.
And he's leading the charge of these
complete World War II lunatics who are
criminals really basically themselves,
their war criminals.
But my point is that that the
incompetence of their way of going about
it shows how desperate they are because
the system that they sit astride of is
no longer functional.
Do you know what I mean?
It a hundred years ago,
200 years ago in the time of imperialism
cleansing and you could win a war,
and that's defined by von Clausewitz
wage,
the war theorists as meaning you now
don't just beat the enemy's army.
You then make the enemies population do
what you want,
and you have a colonial empire and they
produce goods for you and they do things
for you because then you can subdue
them.
But nobody can seem to anybody now.
They just don't get subdued.
Even so much,
you guys,
we saw that and be numb,
but you guys wearing silk,
black little pajamas running around in
pajamas kicked us right out of their
country.
We were,
people were falling off the side of
ships in Da Nang harbor,
falling off helicopters and stuff.
Bunch of guys in pajamas.